hey everyone it's nurse Sarah today I'm
going to show you how to check a blood
glucose using a glucometer so let's get
started whenever you check a blood
glucose using a glucometer you always
want to make sure that you read the
manufacturer's instructions because it
really varies in how they want you to
use the device so first what you want to
do is you want to perform hand hygiene
and educate the patient about the
procedure and have them wash their hands
with warm soap and water this will clean
the hands and that warm water will help
increase circulation so so we can get a
good blood sample then gather the
supplies such as gloves alcohol prep pad
glucometer the Lancing device and Lan
set testing strips and Gauze first what
you want to do is you want to prep the
Lancing device for this particular
device what we're going to do first is
Twist Off the cap of the device then
load the lanet into the device then
Twist Off the needle covering of the
lanet to expose the needle and just to
help prevent sticking yourself with a
needle use the oneand scoop technique to
put the cap back on the device and then
twist this into place next you want to
adjust the puncture depth with this
particular Lancing device we have a
depth from 0 to 5 0 to 1 is for soft
delicate skin 2 to 3 is for normal and
four to 5 is for callous so I'm going to
put it in between 2 to three and then
lastly you want to pull back the plunger
on the device this will springload it
and then set it aside until you're ready
to use now let's prep the sample sight
and the meter we're going to perform
hand hygiene again and Dawn clean gloves
then we want to select a puncture sample
side the fingertips are most commonly
used however check your device because
some devices allow you to use the
forearm or the palm of the hand when
you're using the fingertips you want to
go in at the lateral part of the
fingertips so the side you want to avoid
going in the center and it is not
recommended to massage or milk the
finger prior to sticking it because it
could hemze or dilute the sample with
extra fluid hence plasma which could
alter the glucose result once you've
selected the site you want to clean it
with alcohol prep and let it dry
completely while the sight dries you can
start prepping the meter confirm that
the test strips that you're using are
actually for that device and that
they're not expired once a container of
test strips are open they are good for
90 days be sure to immediately close the
cap back to prevent it from being
exposed to light and air for this device
I will insert the test strip this will
actually turn the device on and now it
is ready for the sample and I'm going to
slightly lower the fingertips so it's
below Heart level this will allow
gravity to pull blood down into the
fingertip so I can get a good sample now
hold the Lancing device firmly against
the side topress the button to activate
the needle and then remove the device a
blood drop should appear at the surface
now to ensure that you get a good sample
collected you can lightly squeeze the
puncture side but do not do this with
intense pressure now some meter devices
may be specific in that they want you to
wipe away the first drop of blood and
use a second drop because it could
contain disinfectant or skin SL tissue
from the puncture however many newer
models do not require this and the
device that I'm using does not require
it so we're going to use the first drop
of blood take the test strip to the
blood sample and touch the sample the
device will absorb the blood through the
test strip once collected set the device
down and weit this device reads in 6
seconds as you're waiting for results
you want to hold firm pressure on that
puncture site with some gauze until it
quits bleeding and patients who take
anti-coagulants may need longer pressure
at this site here are patient's blood
glucose is 99 mg per deciliter we want
to note this result for documentation
purposes then we're going to discard the
strip uncap the Lancing device and use
the safety button to eject the lanet
dispose of this per your facility
protocol then clean the devices DOL
gloves and perform hand hygiene and then
educate the patient on the result and
whenever you're interpreting results you
want to remember that according to the
American Diabetes Association for adults
with diabetes that are not pregnant
these are the following blood glucose
targets before a meal the blood glucose
should run anywhere between 80 to 130 mg
per deciliter or 1 to 2 hours after the
beginning of a meal it should be less
than 180 mg per deciliter